♪ ♪
>> Sean: FORMER
ATTORNEY GENERAL SALLY YATES
CONTESTED THE FRONT OF A
COMMITTEE JUST LIKE
ROD ROSENSTEIN.
TOOK A WHILE BUT THEN SHE
FINALLY HAD TO ADMIT, KNOWING
WHAT SHE KNOWS NOW, SHE NEVER
WOULD’VE SIGNED THE PHONY,
FRAUDULENT, CARTER PAGE PHIS
APPLICATION BASED ON RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION THAT WAS REALLY
USED IT TO SPY ON CANDIDATES
TRUMP AND DEEP INTO THE
PRESIDENCY OF DONALD TRUMP.
TAKE HOW LONG IT TOOK TO ACTUALL
SIMPLE TRUTH.
>> KNOWING THEN WHAT YOU KNOW
NOW WOULD YOU SIGN THAT
APPLICATION?
>> SENATOR, I WOULD NEVER SIGN
ANY DOCUMENT --
>> BECAUSE THAT DOCUMENT WAS A
FRAUD.
IS THAT A FAIR STATEMENT?
IF YOU KNEW THEN WHAT YOU KNOW
NOW, WOULD YOU SIGN IT?
>> I WOULDN’T SIGN ANYTHING IF I
KNEW IT WOULD CONTAIN ERRORS OR
OMISSIONS.
>> DID THAT CONTAIN ERRORS AND
OMISSIONS?
>> YET, AND I WOULD NEVER
KNOWINGLY SIGN A DOCUMENT IN 27
YEARS --
>> I BELIEVE YOU DIDN’T KNOW
WHAT YOU SIGNED WAS WRONG.
THE QUESTION IS, IF YOU HAD
KNOWN, HE WOULDN’T HAVE SIGNED
IT, IS THAT CORRECT?
>> NO, IF I HAD KNOWN IT WOULD
CONTAIN INCORRECT INFORMATION I
CERTAINLY WOULDN’T SIGN.
>> Sean: WE ALSO FOUND OUT
TODAY HOW THERE WAS A BIG
BREAKDOWN IN TERMS OF THE
CARTER PAGE PHIS THE PROCESS.
IT WAS UNVERIFIED, CORROBORATED
AND UNTRUE AND EVERYONE WAS
WARNED AS EARLY AS 2016.
IT WAS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO
THE CARTER PAGE PHIS APPLICATION
AS ANDREW MCCABE
HAS SAID HIMSELF, AND SALLY
YATES REVEALED EVEN MORE OF
COMEY’S BAD BEHAVIOR.
GOING ROGUE TO SET UP A PERJURY
TRAP FOR MICHAEL FLYNN.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE AMBUSH.
>> WHEN YOU LEARNED ABOUT THE
INTERVIEW, YOU GOT UPSET, DIDN’T
YOU?
>> I WAS UPSET THAT COMEY DIDN’T
COORDINATE AND ACTED
UNILATERALLY.
YES, I WAS.
>> OKAY.
IT DID COMEY GO BROKE.
>> YOU COULD USE THAT TERM COMEY
S.
>> Sean: HERE WITH REACTION,
LINDSEY GRAHAM.
GREAT QUESTIONING THERE, THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN YOU AND ME,
YOU SAID I BELIEVE HE DIDN’T
KNOW.
I’M NOT SO SURE I BELIEVE THAT,
SENATOR .
>> BASED ON WHAT I CAN PROVE.
HERE’S WHAT I CAN PROVE,
JIM COMEY HAS BECOME
RADIOACTIVE.
PEOPLE ARE RUNNING AWAY FROM HIM
LIKE HE’S GOT THE PLAGUE.
ROD ROSENSTEIN SAID I WOULDN’T
SIGN THE WARRANT IF I KNEW THEN
WHAT I KNEW NOW.
HE WENT ROGUE, HE SET UP GENERAL
PLAN FOR, AS YOU SAY, TO
MANUFACTURE A CRIME.
WHAT’S THE TAKE AWAY HERE?
I MAY SET ON TOP OF ONE OF THE
MOST CORRUPT INVESTIGATIONS,
CROSSFIRE HURRICANE’S IN THE
HISTORY OF THE FBI, AND THE RATS
ARE JUMPING SHIP.
BAD DAY FOR JIM COMEY.
>> Sean: THAT I AGREE.
AND ALSO, SHE PUTS IN THAT
JANUARY 5TH OVAL OFFICE MEETING,
SHE PUTS THE LOGAN ACT, WHICH
NOBODY’S EVER BEEN PROSECUTED
FOR, BEEN IN EXISTENCE SINCE
1799, SHE PUTS THOSE WORDS IN
THE MOUTH OF JIM COMEY.
>> HERE’S WHAT I CAN TELL YOU.
IF COMEY IS RIDING A BOOK IT
SHOULD BE CALLED "ROGUE."
THE BEST WAY TO DESCRIBE HIS
TENURE AS FBI DIRECTOR IS HE WAS
ROGUE.
HE DIDN’T KNOW THE DOSSIER HAD
BASICALLY PROVED TO BE UNSOUND
BY THE RUSSIAN SUB SORES
INTERVIEW IN JANUARY.
MY GOAL WAS TO PROVE THAT HE DID
KNOW WHEN HE GOT WARRANTS
AGAINST CARTER PAGE ANYWAY.
HERE’S THE POINT.
THEY ARE RUNNING AWAY FROM
CROSS FIRE HURRICANES.
THERE WILL BECOME A TIME TO SELL
YOUR BOOK.
YOU CAN COME TO THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE UNTIL YOUR NEXT BOOK,
BECAUSE YOU’VE GOT A DATE WITH
THE TRUTH, MY FRIEND.
>> Sean: CAN’T WAIT, I WOULD
LIKE TO KNOW WHAT JOHN DURHAM IS
GOING TO DO.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT, WE KNOW HE
WAS WARNED.
IN DETAIL, DON’T TRUST HIM, HE
HAS A POLITICAL AGENDA APPEARED
SIGNED IT ANYWAY.
THEN HE SIGNS IT, THAT WAS THE
BULK OF INFORMATION.
SALLY GATES AND ANDREW MCCABE
SAID NO DOSSIER, YOU DON’T HAVE
A FISA WARRANT, BUT YOU TOLD A
DONALD TRUMP A COUPLE OF MONTHS
LATER IT WAS SALACIOUS AND
UNVERIFIED.
HE LIED IN EITHER CASE.
SOMEBODY, BECAUSE HE IS
CONTRADICTING HIMSELF.
WE ALSO KNOW HE SIGNED ANOTHER
FISA WARRANT AFTER HIS OWN FBI
FOUND OUT THAT NONE OF THIS IS
REAL.
NONE OF THIS IS VERIFIED AND HE
SIGNED IT AGAIN.
THAT IS PREMEDITATED FRAUD ON A
FISA COURT, SENATOR .
WHETHER JIM COMEY, MR. HYER
OWNER WANTS TO ADMIT IT OR NOT.
I GET INDICTED.
WHY HASN’T HE BEEN?
>> I DON’T KNOW WHAT DURUM IS
GOING TO DO BUT I KNOW WHAT I’M
GOING TO DO.
I’M GOING TO CALL THE INTEL
ANALYST WHO INTERVIEWED THOSE
SUB SOURCE IN JANUARY MARCH AND
APRIL AND ASK THEM, ONCE YOU
FOUND OUT THE DOSSIER WAS A
BUNCH OF GARBAGE, DID YOU TELL
ANYBODY ABOUT A CUSTOMER GUY
WILL BE SHOCKED IF THEY DIDN’T
TELL McCABE AND COMAY.
WE’LL GET TO THE BOTTOM OF IT,
STAY TUNED.
ALL I CAN TELL YOU IS A
JIM COMEY IS ABOUT AS
RADIOACTIVE AS YOU CAN GET.
IF YOU DON’T BELIEVE ME, ASK
SALLY YATES.
>> Sean: WHEN ARE YOU CALLING
COMEY?
>> IN SEPTEMBER.
>> Sean: YOU WANT TO MAKE A
BET?
>> WHAT’S THE BET?